nathan novaldi has really been terrific
against the new york yankees three
strong starts against them this year in
which he struck out 20 and he's walked
exactly one man
baldi's going to knock this down scoops
and gets him and a fast out to get le
mayhew no panic there by vivaldi ground
ball back right back at you
he knows it's not that far away not a
fast runner got time gardner's a board
with one away so here is giancarlo
stanton and a swing and a miss he put
him away you never know what you're
going to get and he goes with his split
finger two down for rugnet odor and the
o2 there it is well back to another one
96 yeah
on the mound of fenway yankees really
need a good one a few runs would help in
support too as well it goes hand in hand
you mentioned nathan avaldi and his run
support and of course the scouting
report on jameson he's on a roll we've
mentioned it 4-0 in his last six under
three era [ __ ] hernandez to lead it off
for the red side so the sun's flash
saturday afternoon
pitch oh that's hammered deep shot left
center flory all back looking at the
wall and plays it off the green it
bounces past him [ __ ] taking off
rounding second he wants third here's
the throw oh throw it away
and in he comes to score
and how about that for the first play of
the day offensively for the red sox what
a play from the get-go i think get out
of here get up get out of here it didn't
but he ended up at home though now
here's xander bogart's
and tipped into the glove of brantley so
bogart's down on strikes two-way well
here's rafael devers he could not be
more of a yankee killer
and here he hits a high fly to shallow
center florial comes in to make the
catch and end the enemy
torres to lead things off here against
vivaldi
wave animus with that slider he got him
that's three k's in a row one down
here's greg allen
and dropped in there for strike three
with a curveball this time hello
and four in a row he has whipped and
jd's stuck on second with one down for
kevin plewecki
that's going to be tagged in the left
center field by polwecki that's headed
for the wall that'll bring in another
run
he's off to second the throw is too late
the red sox lead it two to nothing how
about the plowster
getting into one so first and second one
man out here's michael chavis one two
swing and a miss big strikeout that is
his pitch now here's kiki hernandez who
tripled off the high wall
high fly ball
center field on the track is floriale
puts it away for the final out the
yankees eight and nine hitters are
aboard first trouble four of aldi two on
no out
devers
backed up with a good hop down and out
there onto first double play
five four three around the horn go to
red sox two down and here's gardner 02.
swing and a miss boy put him away fast
good morning good afternoon good night
duran will lead things off gizo for
wanna pop to first
in play to the right side and odor
misplays it that skips on by him in the
center durant's taking off for second he
slides in safely oh he is special fast
you might as well show off your speed if
you got it what a great time to do it
too that ball's kind of in the gap once
it got by odor let's see this hop just
ate him up durant over to third infield
in with one down for raphael
i fly ball well hit toward the triangle
not deep enough to get out of the
ballpark but plenty deep to bring in
another run
tagging up durant he is in to score and
that is 80 runs batted in for raffy
devers stanton odor and torres three
four and five for aaron boone's yankees
sometimes the ugliest swings stanton
fans for the second time so torres will
climb in
cut on and miss boy's been devastating
that splitter strikes out torres they go
in order so there is one on and one out
here is cordero
ground ball there's one
and there's two a four six three double
play
down the four no run to hit nobody left
on base we go to the fifth bottom of the
fifth here's michael javis to lead it
off
did he go
yes he did so brantley tags out chavis
chavis does not like the call i think
it's the old paul o'neill thing they
didn't check with the first base umpire
ball
he didn't even go he did not
close he did not go on that i don't
believe he didn't no hernandez has
tripled and then flied out
line drive
caught on one hop by lemay and he gets
hernandez so two down and here is duran
that one is ripped to right field giving
chases allen on the run
covering a lot of ground to make the
play nice play
by greg allen lemay missed a home run by
a foot he's into second base with a
one-out double
swing animus struck him out with a
curveball now stant will climb in here
to right field it hangs up for cordero
franchi in on it makes the play to
retire the side so nothing comes up the
double by le mayhew no martinez is on
with the two-out walk and that will
bring up left-hand hitting alex verdugo
verdugo with a pop-up
and the catch is made by lemayo and the
red sox strand one we go to the seventh
or door lays it off for the yankees in
the top of the seven oh two
up the middle on one bounce that's
debra's to sling it on to get him here's
global torres another hesitation
lob toward right cordero makes the
sliding play
nice smooth effort by franchi and two
down allen aboard with two down and
sends up chris kittens allen very good
speed over there in first base jam shot
here bogarts
bare hands
scoop by chavis and got him
now the defensive play of the day for
the red sox by the shortstop and the
first baseman
lewicki has had a perfect day he's
getting a game to play as they rest
vasquez
and a swing and a miss plowecki down on
strikes two-way and that will bring up
gardiner and the o2
line drive it's a base hit to right
field cordero fields scoring easily as
floreal and it's an rbi single for
gardner and that does bring up stanton
as the tying run in the bottom of the
eighth and stanton is the trying run as
he stands in
popped up shallow right coming on
cordero it's a base hit and it's going
to bounce into the seats for a double
and that'll move gardner over to third
though second and third two man out here
is ruby odor
and he swings at the first pitch and
lost it deep to left field and verdugo
will play it off the wall
and that ties the game two-run score on
the double by odor and it is 3-3
and here's gleber torres
and he lofts that one to shallow right
that could find grass and it does odor
will score
it is a single and an rbi for torres and
the yankees have come all the way back
they lead the red sox four to three
so anyway the boston has first and third
two out and here's jd martinez
he swings at the first pitch and lofts
it to right field
allen is there runs into floreal and
allen makes the play for the final out
exhale one down top of the order here's
d.j lameah
swinging a high fly ball that's well
struck duran is under though
and he's got it and they're going to
double him up the runner forgot how many
outs there were here's the throw into
first base and that's a double play
brantley with a major mistake there just
totally forgot how many outs there were
renfro with a tough about walks as a
pinch hitter and that's going to bring
up christian vasquez pinch hitting for
chavis the 2-2 pitch
high-fly ball right field on the run
allen it's a basic and it bounces into
the seats for a double but now second
and third two minutes hernandez is one
for four chapman deals
swinging and a miss he did it the
yankees hold on and they win four to
three